america is the land that prides itself
on thinking big they made the Hoover Dam
went to the moon built the shuttle the
modern city changed the world of
entertainment and the way the world
functions when America faced a big
problem it's found a big answer there's
no doubt Americans still think their
country's special but there is this real
sense of a national lack of confidence
right now
the feeling that just maybe America has
somehow lost its mojo
they've been predicting the end of the
American dream for years but a no
previous election as America's decline
being such a big issue for the first
time the majority of Americans now doubt
that our children will have a better
future a nation in debt a nation in
doubt a nation in decline of course the
economy isn't where it needs to be
there's a theory that the 9/11 attacks
now more than a decade ago with a moment
this bright confident new nation lost
its innocence too long and hugely
expensive wars have also dealt a heavy
blow to America's can-do optimism and
the economic crisis has further battered
the mood not since the Great Depression
has there been such a sense of financial
hopelessness
America is at least 16 trillion dollars
in debt that much of that debt is owed
to its rival superpower China a picture
of dynamism and boom growing wealthy
middle class making and selling products
the world wants that used to be America
seeing that happen with an old Cold War
foe that's hard to take the economic
stats on home soil make grim reading
young Americans are having to get used
to the fact that they're going to be
poorer than their parents generation and
when the American Dream tells you that
everyone is supposed to get richer and
richer that feels like a broken promise
the paradox is that while Americans feel
downbeat about the economy today they're
optimistic it will get better when they
don't have faith is in their politicians
the approval rating for the US Congress
barely scrapes into double figures these
days
well politicians from both parties used
to talk about working together for the
good of the country there's now gridlock
and a refusal to cooperate and
differences between factions across the
country are only deepening Americans
want to dream again but they're not sure
who's going to make that happen